Speaker 1: We are taking phone calls, sort
of they're really kind of like VoIP calls,
I guess, through The David Pakman Show discord,
which you can find at David Pakman dotcom
slash discord.
Let's go to I believe it's Nikkie from Germany.
Nikkie from Germany.
Is that right?
Niki from Germany, you're on the air.
Niki from Germany, last chance.
And Nicky from Germany is gone.
Let's go to Bryce from Illinois.
Bryce, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Fantastic, how are you doing today?
I'm doing well.
Good, so I've just got, I guess, a couple
quick questions, kind of joking mildly, just
that I don't get the break, the guy's a little
bit.
And then I guess more of a serious question,
if that's all right.
That works with you.
OK.
So first question, boxers or briefs?
Speaker 1: Oh, I, I have a video on YouTube
about this, so I refuse to answer it in perpetuity.
You just have to go and look at the boxers
or briefs video on YouTube.
Speaker 2: Oh, I see.
Enough.
I guess my other question is, you live in
New York City, right?
Speaker 1: Near New York City, yeah, I don't
say exactly where.
Speaker 2: OK, fair enough, but I guess what's
your transport situation like between, I guess,
your home and office?
Speaker 1: I have not been on I have not been
on public transport since February of twenty
twenty.
Speaker 2: I just.
What do you do in order to get around, you
have a car.
I have a car.
I've been getting really into small, unique
electric vehicles lately, have electric unicycles,
a whole host of interesting things.
So just out of curiosity, more than anything,
but none of these are serious questions.
So I guess I'll propose a more serious question.
Have you seen the film, Idiocracy by Mike
Judge?
Yes, I have.
What do you think the odds are with, you know,
the 50 percent of the Republican Party that
refuses to acknowledge that Joe Biden won
the election?
Do you think that that 50 percent could potentially
weigh us down enough to where that is a reasonably
valid situation that could happen if we don't
blow ourselves up for him?
Speaker 1: I don't know specifically what
which part you mean, but yes, I've expressed
significant concern about the fact that disagreements
about what the tax rate should be or how big
a, you know, housing
Speaker 2: just the apparent complete lack
of trust in science.
Yes.
Speaker 1: That's extremely concerning.
That is extremely concerning.
I don't know how we fix it.
And we've talked about it quite a bit.
All right.
Thank you, my friend.
Appreciate the call.
I'm going to move on a bit.
Let's talk to Andrew from Miami.
Andrew, you were on the air.
Hi, David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: I'm wondering what your thoughts
are on Biden running on things like canceling
student debt or providing a public option,
and then when he actually gains power, he
doesn't really seem to have the means or desire
to enact any of those policies.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, I would take
issue I don't know that Biden ran on canceling
student debt.
I think that towards the end of the campaign,
pressure made him say he'd consider canceling
some amount of it, but not fifty thousand
dollars.
I think he was talking about ten.
Needless to say, as I said before, I don't
think he really has any interest in doing
it.
And on that, it's just he's just not interested
in it.
And I disagree with him on the policy.
But Joe Biden never seemed to me interested
in actually doing that.
Now, on the public option, health care is
he did covid stimulus and that tweaked Obamacare
to some degree.
And now he's got infrastructure, the jobs
plan, tax reform.
I am still open to the idea that Joe Biden
will make a good faith effort to put a public
option in place.
He may not do it.
He may not do it because he doesn't try hard
enough or he may not do it because he's not
able to get it done.
I'm reserving judgment until we see because
we're only four months into his presidency.
Speaker 2: What does it mean to you to not
try hard enough to get something as significant
as public health option?
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I mean, Joe, you
sort of know it when you see it.
Joe Biden touts how he's been a dealmaker
who can negotiate with Democrats and Republicans
for his entire career.
So if Joe Biden simply says, I'd like a public
option, that would be a great thing.
And, you know, three Democrats say we don't
want it and then you never hear about it again.
I think most of us would sort of agree that's
not really trying giving that's not really
giving a good faith effort.
If he puts together a proposal with Democrats
that want it and it includes a public option,
and when whoever Joe Manchin or whatever comes
out and says, I don't want that, he brings
them to the White House and he meets and any
lobbies and he pushes, I think we will all
know whether it was a good faith effort or
not.
Speaker 2: Well, I mean, that sort of reminds
me of the discussion that came around the
15 dollar minimum wage, you know, he's supposed
to be this great.
I mean, we don't want to say dealmaker because
that reminds us of the previous administration.
Yeah, but if you're supposed to bring together
Democrats and Republicans to enact things
that are overwhelmingly popular with the public,
the 15 hour minimum wage sort of fell through
and he sort of let that happen by saying something
along the lines of, you know, we don't think
it'll pass given the current, you know.
Speaker 1: Yeah, he didn't even I mean, listen,
he didn't even have every Democratic senator
on board.
It was there was just no way.
And as I've spoken about before, we can argue
that morally the parliamentarian should have
included it and let them all vote no.
And but in practice, it would have just delayed
people getting a covid cash.
That's in practice what it would have done.
We would have a naughty and nice list, but
we sort of do anyway.
We sort of know who is against it.
So I agree with you.
I don't think there was any way anything would
happen other than just delaying people get
for getting fourteen hundred dollars.
And I'm for the 15 dollar minimum wage to
be clear.
Speaker 2: Great.
That's great to hear.
It just seems so interesting how when things
come up in terms of propagating the war machine
or other things involving funding the private
sector, it always seems like that money is
available.
But when it comes to funding and fifteen dollars
minimum wage, of course, those things are
more difficult to happen.
Speaker 1: One hundred percent that we never
question.
Where will we get the money for all these
bombs and missiles and rockets?
One hundred percent.
Right.
And that's an analysis I've been making for
some time.
And you couldn't be more right.
Speaker 2: Excellent.
Glad you agree.
Thanks so much, David.
Speaker 1: All right.
I'm going to let you go.
The audio really sort of kind of falling apart
there towards the end, but it's sort of held
to some degree for a period
of time.